i think they'll look back and say i
cannot believe i behaved so
disgracefully i can't believe
i smeared all these people as nazis i
can't believe i i lost my senses and i
do believe that will happen hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people uh brilliant and
returning for the hundredth time today
guests
103rd time guest today is a comedian
satirist writer the creator of
tania mcgrath brilliant a friend of the
show who's been on as i say many many
times
andrew doyle welcome back to
trigonometry it is a great pleasure to
be here again
as you say it's becoming interminable
yes well
you know what it's funny it's and it's a
special moment for us because
this is probably i think the fourth time
we've had you on
is that right at least plus we've done
some live shows together as well
but as we are recording this we're about
to break through 200 000 subscribers on
youtube which is a lot
we're pleased and you were actually
probably our first sort of big
guest that did very well i remember
being the same i was the sec
in the second episode yeah yeah and back
then you had a very different format it
was very minimalist you know not none of
this sort of elaborate set that you've
got going on now
yeah it was [ __ ] atrocious
i liked it it was just the three of us
around the table it looked like a seance
yeah spotlight it had that sort of eerie
quality
which i miss in a way yeah he's lost
weight i've lost hair we've all moved on
yeah everything changes it's all for the
good it's all good
so for the good but listen man it's good
to have you back uh with the reason we
thought we'd get you back on is
you know it's been an interesting year
to say the least a lot has been going on
uh and uh you know we we spent obviously
the whole year talking about it in a
serious way with a lot of people but
we just thought it's been such an
absolute i i nearly said the word [ __ ]
[ __ ] i don't know why
cluster whatever whatever it's been uh
we just thought we'd spend the last week
sort of trying to cheer people up and
have a light-hearted conversation about
what's going on
even though we will touch on the serious
stuff as well so of all the things that
have happened this year what has stood
out for you
as as the sort of epitome of 2020
it's very difficult to say because
ultimately the year
in of itself has been sort of the moment
i think it's going to be very important
moment historically
because it's the moment when everything
that we've been warning about for the
last five six years
has come to fruition so it's just been
the complete um
explosion of the culture war into the
mainstream so whereas
uh i've always and i know you have as
well i've always had to
deal with this accusation that you're
talking about a straw man you're talking
about something that doesn't exist
you're talking about
a few uh overzealous students on campus
getting upset about certain things
you're talking about a few overzealous
columnists etc
and now of course the evidence of
everything we've been talking about is
everywhere so so people have actually
stopped saying that to me now you can't
it's not sustainable anymore
so all of those all of those elements of
of the kind of post-modern
social justice movement or ideology or
whatever you want to call it
has now just completely broken through
and it's not really a matter of
these things bubbling under the surface
anymore uh it's just a matter of
acknowledging that they are out there
front and center
and now it's a case of what do we do
about it so i think
when it comes to pinpointing something
from the year it's very very difficult
i think i think what's but what's quite
interesting is is seeing
how seeing how that change has become
actuated if you go back to january if
you think about the story in january
when
when over 300 guardian staff members
signed a petition against suzanne moore
at the guardian because they perceived
something she'd written was
was um was transphobic and i think this
actually was this in february anyway it
was back near the start of the year
and uh you know that now i mean back
then people were
saying this is ridiculous i can't
believe this is happening now that would
be seen
as just well that's completely normal
that's completely standard the such has
been
the the sort of transition uh from a
relatively sane society
to this pseudo reality that we now
occupy so it's it's it's a weird one
and andrew how much of uh of that is due
to social media the fact that we're
cooped up in our houses and we tend to
be
mainlining twitter into our eyeballs i
don't know i mean this is the thing i'm
not
i've i'm not an anthropologist or a i'm
not
in a position to say why all this has
happened a lot of people have speculated
that there's been this
as you say a kind of pressure cooker
environment and the early in the year
because everyone was cooped up under
lockdown this is why after the george
floyd moment
uh the explosion happened this is why
people were out there rioting
uh this is why everything went so insane
so quickly
it it so if there is a psychological
reasoning behind it then then i i
i i find that persuasive but i'm
probably not in a position
uh to make the judgment as to its
validity but yeah i think that's
i think that's true i'm always wrestling
with this idea of should i just get off
social media and then
but i mean i sort of depend on it for
what i do
um and and the problem isn't so much
that i mean you're absolutely right what
is it
80 percent of the country are not on are
not on twitter
and and the people who are on twitter i
think it's something like only five to
ten percent of the people who do most of
the tweets right so it's it's a
twitter and social media generally such
a small uh minority
that's why so many people just don't
know about this stuff but the problem is
that
now it's very clear that the social
media discourse
is in is is driving the rest of it so
so stuff that last year we would have
heard from
um the most overzealous blue check
academics on twitter is now being
parroted by
sadiq khan say or people in parliament
or or you know the sort of mainstream
voices or the headmaster of eaton
or whatever you know so so that's the
problem
it it it wouldn't matter if we could
just disregard the whole of social media
and just say oh look they're not cases
they're insane they're
they are and there's there is that
element of of what rickard race talks
about like
being able to see you know it's like
being exposed to the scrawlings on the
toilet
wall now that's what that's what it is
it's just it's all there for you to see
the problem is that the scrawlings on
the toilet wall
never directed popular discourse before
never never never migrated into
parliament and into education and into
the
media and into journalism and all the
rest of it so that's the
that's the really dangerous thing now
and i don't know how you reverse that
really
yeah well we're keeping a light already
at the top of the show so that's great
did you yeah did you want this to be a
bit more frivolous and flippant no no no
i'm just joking mate
that was my way of injecting a bit of
levity into it but you know i was
wondering
one of the accusations that i think all
three of us to some extent have always
got is that
uh like we're delighted that this is
happening we're so happy because it
validates what
we've been saying it it gives us a job
it's like all of that stuff and i i
can't tell you how how desperately
frustrated i am that everything
you and i and francis and everybody else
has been saying is is turning out to be
correct
oh i know i agree i want to be wrong i
want to be wrong i want it to go away
uh you know i mean when people say that
to me i just think well that's really
weird because my job
never depended on this you know i've
i've always
written plays and articles and and
comedy
and and in the comedic sense i've always
mocked the stuff in society that i
perceive to be ridiculous which is what
we all do and this is the stuff that i
currently perceive to be ridiculous i'm
obviously going to talk about this
the idea that that this is what is
sustaining my livelihood
is isn't true for one thing uh that is
not to say i don't earn money
out of the comedy that i write i do but
if it was if this wasn't going on i'd be
mocking something else and earning money
that way you know that's what
it's it's a very weird accusation isn't
it that you're you're cashing in
by doing what you do for a living that
would mean that absolutely everyone is
cashing in whenever they accept a
paycheck it doesn't make any sense
um i would love to i would love for this
to go away it'd be it'd be absolutely
wonderful
if the titanium mcgrath character was
redundant it would be a dream come true
i want all of this stuff to stop i want
uh society to get back to just being
sane again that would be that would be
great
but it's not it's not
it's far from it it's not it isn't have
we as rod little
uh quoted many many times have we
reached peak wank yet andrew
is that what he said yeah um yeah
he didn't say we have it's just a term
that you use yeah
uh so what you're really asking me is
can it get any worse
yes and i know the answer to this but i
feel it's important that we do it anyway
well you know the obvious
truth is yes it can um and it probably
will um i
i think you know we've seen over the
last week or so
uh the law commission trying to push for
greater hate speech regulation which
would include
uh criminalizing things that are said in
the home it would in
include um a policing offensive comedy
uh
the the thing that they keep mentioning
in the document is the uh
the the cartoons of muhammad for
instance so
so satire would be so it's going the
other way you know what
what all of this stuff should be doing
is like a wake-up call and people
should be saying okay well let's abolish
hate speech laws let's let's just repeal
all of that stuff
let's get back to liberal values let's
do all but we're not going the other way
and it's you know
everyone got a bit crazy when hamza
yousef and the snp started pushing their
hate crime bill
through which they are still uh
proceeding with and uh
but there was some consolation that well
that's just scotland but now the law
commission want that to be rolled out to
england and wales as well
um so obviously if that kind of stuff
gets enacted then things are going to
get a lot worse a lot
quicker i mean people were very shocked
weren't they at the start of the year
when uh it was reported that 120 000
non-crime hate incidents had been
recorded by police over the last five
years and that is a shocking figure
uh well just imagine once if this law
commission's proposals
are taken on board it's going to be a
lot lot worse
that kind of thing so yeah i i mean i'm
not
the thing is i try to be obvious sirens
in the background they're coming for
andrew right now
yeah they probably are i mean no look
i don't want to be i don't want to
catastrophize that's the first thing so
i don't i don't
like talking about the idea that we're
in this utter crisis and
we're going to end up in the gulags and
all the rest because i don't think
that's true
i think we're still in that a precarious
position where we can see
the fissures breaking in the barricades
that we put up to protect our
civilization we can see those
fissures widening and and what you
always have to do in every subsequent
generation
is is defend free speech anew and defend
liberal values and new it's not
something that can just be taken for
granted so
um so i think it's very important that
we do without catastrophizing if
possible
um and and also i think when you do that
you give ammunition to the people who
say that this is all just a concocted
thing of the right
you know um so i i think
let's acknowledge that we're not living
in a soviet-style scenario
at the moment um but we also need to be
wary
when it comes to these uh the this
erosion of our
our fundamental values and and rights so
you know
yes it can get worse and answer your
question yes it probably will get worse
and then hopefully in about 10 years
time everyone will say god do you
remember all that stuff
that was nuts wasn't it what happened
and what would be even better is if the
people who are
the practitioners of council culture who
deny its existence
if in 10 15 years time they look at
their own behavior and say i can't
believe
we we just lost our minds we just went
all hysterical for a moment
we started believing in all these
invisible power structures we start we
became religious
for a while there and and now we've
realized that
you know all of that was was just folly
i that's my hope
it's interesting the the extent to which
it's god though because
you would probably have seen there's a
story about a
black boy who was sent
a video of his classmate singing along
to a rap song using the n-word
and he saved it for three years
waited until she applied to university
and then released it for maximum impact
and she got her place at that university
canceled
and it so i think one of the concerns
for me and where i agree with you about
it getting worse is that
this is now being embedded into young
people's psyches where they think this
sort of behavior is normal
and you talk about comparisons with the
soviet union i mean obviously i grew up
there
you know the story of pavlik morozov the
boy who reported his
his father to the authorities it's very
reminiscent i mean
the i'm not saying there are gulags but
the way of thinking is very much the
same no
i'm not denying that at all i think
you're absolutely right and it's it the
these the tactics of cancer culture are
from
they are based on a totalitarian
instinct
um that particular story is very
troubling because of course
it's so calculated isn't it and then of
course and then it was endorsed by the
new york times and then you have people
uh chipping in and saying well this is
good because it means there's one less
racist at university
who you know it's like someone is
condemned for
uh uh something they said when they're
15 and there's no redemption it's it's
it's not about redemption it's about
it's about just constant punishment
throughout your life you are you know
so yeah all of that is utterly
reminiscent and you're right to
to point out the echoes because that's a
a really good way
uh to expose it and to explain why we
need to guard against it i absolutely
think that's i no i'm not i'm not
denying that you should make the
comparison the comparison is true
i mean the entire social justice
movement is essentially totalitarian and
revisionist that's
that is what it is that's what the you
know i mean this is why you get the odd
denial
of history and i'll give you a very very
clear example of this which pertains to
us i think
so you'll have noticed there's a lot of
articles and writers for the guardian
now denying that the word woke was ever
used
to describe this movement the social
justice ideology they just say this is a
word that's been concocted by
right-wingers and the conservatives
to smear us right but you go back to
2018
when nika burns gave that opening speech
to the edinburgh festival fringe in
which she talked about
how she was looking forward to the new
woke world of comedy
she was saying she was looking forward
to the next generation of woke comedians
who are going to set
the parameters for what is acceptable to
talk about no one
no one who reported on that said hold a
minute isn't that word woke just a
conservative word that isn't it
no everyone knew that that's just the
word that they used to describe
themselves
uh the guardian repeatedly talked about
wokeness and the woke world and all the
rest of it in its own
articles without irony and the good
thing is we've got the internet that can
prove it
but they just gaslight everyone to use
their own term they just
are now determined to say that it was a
word they never used at all i think
what's actually happened
is because people like you and i mocked
the term throughout 2019
now the word is used by some as a slur
and a smear
so now they pretend that they didn't use
it themselves so they're just completely
and they just say this they just say
what is probably not true
in the way that cnn can report can have
a reporter with with
the city burning behind him saying that
these are largely peaceful protests or
the bbc can tell you that
a a protest in which 29 police officers
were injured is
mostly peaceful so you know it it's the
very definition of gaslighting which is
that term they gave to us
it's the term that they accuse other
people of doing even their accusation of
gaslighting is a form of gaslighting
because they themselves
are the ones that do it it's just this
i'm really fascinated by this complete
uh this complete failure
to engage with reality to push a false
reality when the evidence
is there before our eyes and they expect
people just to go along with it
that's how little they regard uh
humanity they think that humanity is so
stupid and malleable that they can just
flat out deny reality
you know in the way donald trump used to
he'll say i didn't say that
and then you go on youtube and there he
is saying it it's like this is
infantile stuff and i think it's
something that
i'm hoping in 2021 everyone will kind of
get over or at least have the courage to
say
that's not true what you said just isn't
true you know
do you watch problematic content online
of course they do they watch
trigonometry
many isps log your internet activity
and sell that data on to other big tech
companies
or other advertising companies i know
that is why
i use expressvpn to hide my browsing
activities i bet you do
expressvpn is a simple app that you can
have on both your computer
and your smartphone which hides your
traffic into one channel
and directs it through a vpn server
which means your isp can't see anything
that you're doing
look the question i want to ask no will
it slow down the videos that i watch
definitely not that is one of the
reasons it's been rated as the number
one
vpn app by cnet and wyatt i don't read
those publications because i'm not a
nerd
stop handing over your personal data to
isps and big tech companies which are
just going to use it and sell it on
visit expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r
e s s v p n
dot com slash trigger i love it when you
spell things out but it gets even better
than that
expressvpn are offering trigonometry
fans three
extra months free go to expressvpn.com
slash trigger to learn more
the fight back has started as new if you
look at
for instance with brexit the brexit
negotiations have finally come to an end
we've signed the deal we've now
officially left the european union
surely 2021 we're going to see more of a
push back against this
maybe but i don't think they're going to
let the brexit thing go
because again they're they're doing the
gaslighting thing they're saying that uh
nobody knew what they were voted for
there was no political debate nobody
ever discussed the customs union no
it'd be able to discuss the single
market again you can go to youtube
you can check the biggest debates of the
time the one that was in wembley arena
for god's sake
where within five minutes they're
talking about what it would mean to
leave the customs union in a single
market you know
all that so they won't accept it
i don't think um so
i i don't believe it it is the end of it
i think you've started the
the rejoin eu hashtag is now trending uh
people are going on about gammons again
uh people
uh pushing the idea that you are looking
rather gammony today i must say andrew
am i looking a bit gaming yeah you are
you know this is so offensive to me
because you know i'm a vegetarian
very very upsetting very upsetting thing
um
yeah you know no i don't think they are
gonna let it go and they're going to
cling to this myth that this was all
about
race they're going to cling to the myth
that you know it's it's it's
it's very interesting isn't it that this
comes predominantly from middle-class
people who don't know any working-class
people and don't know any lead voters
so it's very easy i had a conversation
just before christmas
with someone i hadn't met before and she
was saying to me that she was utterly
shocked because she started going about
how
you know people voted brexit because
they were racist and i said well i voted
brexit and she was genuinely shocked she
said but i've never met anyone who voted
leave and she was and then we got to
talking
and by the end of the conversation she
almost came around to my way of thinking
because because you know they just
haven't
they've just willingly blocked their
ears to the reasons why
the genuine reasons why people voted and
substituted it
for this very simplistic reductive good
versus evil thing which does make it
it's an easier way of thinking you know
i understand it you know
our brains are built that way that we
always go for the easiest way of
thinking but it's it's lazy
um they're not gonna let that go i mean
i've already seen people talking still
about this idea that people wanted an
empire but you know
the people voted leave wanted their
empire back i i mean i couldn't
i couldn't find someone who thinks that
if i tried i wouldn't know where to
begin
where would you find someone who thinks
that that it's just not a thing
that those you know you could probably
find one or two nut cases and i'm sure
the bbc have done their best to find
those nutcases
and interview them because it promotes
that narrative but it's really not a
thing
and yet you had vince cable you know a
major politician giving a talk
where he talked about how the brexit
vote was because people missed the days
of
white faces and blue passports and a
pink
map you know the empire map and it's
like nobody thinks this and this just
goes to show
how isolated they are in their own
fantasies it's just lots of people
talking to each other reaffirming each
other's false beliefs false view of
reality
and that can't be sustainable can it i
mean you
you can only live that way for so long
you know you've got to you've got to
you've got to confront reality at some
point and i think that's going to be our
that's going to be our battle really is
is finding a way
to to to guide people back from their
fantasy world
uh and into the real world and i don't
know you know i'm not sure how you do
that
uh but that's gonna be that's gonna be
the big uh the big
battle of 2021 i believe one of the big
battles
that i think is going to happen in 2021
is
we've touched that it's well
some people more than others but
certainly whether the
bbc has any sort of sustainable future
what are your opinions on it and do you
think that it's
we should be funding it publicly it's
really difficult i mean
you know i i think that over the
you know it's very difficult to be
politically impartial as as a
as a broadcaster and i think and i think
it's very hard
you know uh someone like andrew neal is
utterly brilliant at this because he
will always
challenge whoever he's interviewing
irrespective of his own personal beliefs
and that's what the that that should be
the sort of ideal
and and you know they will be damned
whatever they do you know they've been
called
that they've said that there's people
say accuse them of having an
institutional left-wing bias
people also accuse him of being an
institutional right-wing buyers for
instance against jeremy corbyn
you know so so that's very hard
but i think what is and i said i have a
kind of sympathy in a way
um uh when it comes to that because i
just don't know how you fully monitor
that
but i think what is indisputable is that
they are systemically woke
i think there's no getting around that
that and that is so built in um
and woke isn't about a left right thing
it's not
um and and so it's it's so built into
every in
to the way they think the way they
perceive i mean i just i scrolled
through some
bbc article the other day and they were
they were spelling female
fem xle and and you know it's it's like
well
the very fact that you do that and you
don't even question that is is
is evidence of this kind of systemic
wokeness so
i don't know how they unpick that i
don't know how
they would begin to do it um i think
it's just too
built in you know i've had enough
conversations with people who work at
the bbc
and this is not said that everyone that
works in the bbc feels this way but
everyone at the bbc knows that they have
to
toe the line on this they they really do
i've had
i've had a situation where i was on a
bbc show
as as you know as you and i always are
the token [ __ ]
what you know evil bigger whatever it is
uh
what i mean is they basically get you on
to say the thing that a lot of them
think but no one is supposed to say at
the bbc
and so you i constantly find myself in
this position where
i am asked onto a show and on on
on camera i am asked to defend positions
which are presented as unreasonable and
weird and whatever
antagonistic whereas off camera the
producer is saying to me
actually you know what i you know i
don't agree with this
you know that or whatever so there is
that conflict at the heart of it and i'm
not someone who particularly wants the
bbc to be defunded
but on the other hand i do agree with
you i think yes on economics they may
not be particularly left or right or
may even lean to the right who knows but
when it comes to this work stuff
they are very systemically work and how
how you unpick that i don't know but
maybe we should broaden it out to the
media more generally because i think
one of the things that has happened this
year is you know
i think the war in iraq and and
mp's expenses those were things that
massively undermined people's
confidence in in the institutions of the
establishment
like the media and government but i
think this year has been particularly
bad for the media
because there have been so many
polarizing events which they have just
shown their true colors on
i think that's it they just have to
really maintain a rigorous high
standard you know when you remember when
the uh there was that gathering the
brexit gathering i think it was
trafalgar square and
it was a bbc representative who was who
was uh
focusing on whiteness and the white the
whiteness of the crowd and that kind of
thing and jon snow
sorry well no that was the channel for
example right all right
but it also happened with the bbc it was
it was a similar thing and then
and every time that happened and of
course they don't say that at an
extinction rebellion
gathering which which is basically like
a white rally
you know so they don't do that then and
and those moments you see
will always be seized upon uh by
by the critics of the bbc and rightly so
and it makes their position
unsustainable so i think always with the
media it's about holding yourself to
incredibly high standards and and
that will be the way the way through it
and not saying things that are palpably
false for instance not editorializing as
we saw with with
night you know just just being really
sharp on that and making sure that that
doesn't happen you know there's a reason
why people don't take channel 4 news
seriously anymore
because it beca because it is
effectively just a
mouthpiece for the social justice
ideology and so people don't really
you know i mean all the people i know
who used to read the guardian they do
still
but they don't really take it that
seriously now and and
so people are shooting themselves in the
foot so
yeah i mean and it is a worry i talked
to peter pagosa about this recently
he used the phrase the legitimation
crisis and this idea of the legitimation
crisis is this concept that where
we no longer have any faith in authority
figures and that can be the media
it can be politicians but it can also be
academic academics and academia and all
of that is happening
uh concurrently so we're losing faith in
all of these major institutions
at the same time and and that's a very
very
fundamental and dangerous uh precarious
situation to be in because it it it
means that you do get this
destabilization of reality that's where
we are now and actually it's really
important to have i mean
i'm all for a public broadcaster that
holds the powerful to account
which of course is what the the bbc is
meant to do and so i am
troubled um when when it fails
maybe maybe it fails to be impartial but
more than that it fails to be perceived
as being impartial and that that the
perception is absolutely everything
you know and we saw this in america
donald trump very successfully
cast aspersions on the on the on the
media
but it wasn't helped by the fact that
the media often did represent
what he said so the simple solution to
that is just
tell us the news right don't don't tell
us what to think about the news
all the time don't preach at us all the
time just tell us what's happening
and then we'll we'll do the rest but
andrew
isn't the problem that you've got this
like you said this work ideology is in
all these media corporations but if the
people in these corporations
have this ideology you're never going to
change it
no but they like you said a lot of them
don't you know i i think it's just the
ones that
do are terrifying i i think that's all
it is right so that
the people who will you know the people
who you're nervous about speaking in the
meeting with
yeah i i wrote an article about this
reason because before the lockdown and
all the rest of it happened early in the
year
friend of mine was putting on a play and
the director was extremely woke and
extremely
you know always looking for something to
be offended by always calling out white
privilege and toxic masculine and all
this sort of stuff
he said that he found himself treating
her like uh like a dangerous
dog insofar as because what you do is
you
you're really careful not to upset it
because it'll bite and and that's that's
the way people behave around and i don't
think
i don't think a lot of the woke people
know this about themselves how
scary they are how people just shut up
when they're around because they don't
want to risk
um being open god knows what this does
to their relationships
or to their friendships um i think a lot
of them might be quite turned on by that
revelation
andrew if i'm honest with you mate also
just on another point um
we treat dangerous dogs very differently
in russia apparently you put them down
right
yeah yeah that's what we do i'm not
advocating for that to happen to work
people now when you're know it's a very
brutal
race we we are more kind of
compassionate over here
um but is a word you're looking for
you must all be put down constantin
how do you like your things printed big
like my ego and that's why you should
use
print it big 3d what they actually do is
help you print
tabletop gaming pieces short run
manufacturing parts
and even statues from your favorite
movies and tv shows so you can get
ned stark without his head on they also
make
cosplay costumes car parts and weapons
but not real ones obviously and the
wonderful people that they are
they also make free prosthetics for kids
what virtue signalers
on top of that they also do individual
pieces
prototypes and short run manufactured
parts
do you know what any of that means not a
clue print printer big
3d are offering our fans a massive
discount you get
20 off with our code which is of course
trigger pod
all you need to do is go to the website
www.printitbig3d.com
that's www.printitbig3d.com
i'm going to get francis a new weapon i
like weapons
but what i would say to return to the
dog metaphor actually
i'll give you a better example i was
talking to a young
comedian on the circuit this was last
year a new comedian to the circuit
and she said to me that she every week
she goes to these open mic gigs and
every week
she has to go up to comedians afterwards
and tell them what they should and
shouldn't have been joking about
and she has to go up and berate them for
the things that they've done
and she said to him and what was weird
about this she said you've no idea how
exhausting this is to me
that i have to do this and i shouldn't
have to do this you should be helping
people like you should be standing up
and seriously and i'm surprised no one's
no one's punched her you know like this
isn't like this is incredible this kind
of
but it was a sincere expression of
exasperation
why can't the whole world just change to
suit what i want
why can't that just happen you know it's
it's it's this general
infantile mentality that suggests a real
lack
of education there's something gone
wrong in our educational system that
that
people think like this that they act
like babies
um and and scary babies they're
terrifying babies you know i can't think
of anything
more frightening than someone coming up
to me after a gig and saying you
shouldn't have said this and here look
i've made a list of the things you
should have said and
but doing it from the position of valor
and virtue i mean this is like
this is nuts so yeah i think i think
and that's why to go back to the bbc
point is that
even if it's a minority of people at the
bbc it doesn't matter because
everyone at the bbc knows they're not
getting the promotion
if they don't tow this line everyone
knows that
everyone knows that programs aren't
going to be commissioned if they mock
the social justice movement in any way
that's not going to happen
um you know you have insiders at the bbc
telling the guardian
well there are no funny anti-woke comics
well
i don't think i i mean i think i think
all comic or
comics are anti-wonk really aren't they
all comics mock the prevailing
orthodoxies and the you know
um i mean all that person was saying is
they don't find it funny because it
upsets them i mean that's fine i
wouldn't expect them to find it funny
but it's just simply not true what
they're saying and you know
the idea that that there's a meritocracy
when it comes to comedies is is utterly
ludicrous um
so it is ideological so if you're in if
you're working within those
circumstances of course you're going to
shut up because you don't want the viper
to turn on you
it's just it's it just makes sense so
how you combat that
i think the only way is is a kind of
a collective courage when
everyone just says what they think and
we don't get this
preference falsification where
everyone's just saying what they think
other people want to hear
or they're saying the things that they
think won't get them in trouble if
everyone just says what they honestly
believe
then i mean imagine what society would
be like it'd be amazing
if there's no jobs anyway so you can't
lose your job well that's true
that's true you know just it's horrible
isn't it in a way because
uh in order to effect this change you
have to accept that a lot of people are
going to fall you know
a lot of people are going to end up
fired if they do if they take my advice
a lot of people get fired
right but but maybe you have to just
maybe that just has to happen
it's very easy for me to say isn't it
because well you know
something i always mentioned to francis
is that this is what alexander
solzhenitsyn talked about in the gulag
archipelago he said that if ordinary
people had stood up and resisted
minor tyrannies as they happened then
the major tyrannies wouldn't have been
possible yeah
um but yeah sorry go ahead no um
with alexander solzhenitsyn oh yeah
[ __ ] mate
but uh one thing that i wanted to ask is
look we touch on this again and again
and we've touched on it with various
guests
well i've got a friend he's an academia
he was like do you think i should come
out and say something
and he's right at the beginning of his
career as an academic
and my honest advice is no coward why
would you
sacrifice your career why would you make
yourself effectively unemployable
because of your beliefs if you know
nobody around you is going to speak up
and say anything
when when when we got canceled nobody on
the in the
in the club even people who messaged me
privately spoke up
because if you don't then this will
never end
i suppose is the answer to that um
yeah i mean it's hard look because i'm
speaking as someone who
has never been censored i i i've never
been cancelled i say what i want
and actually part of my job now depends
on saying what i want so
it's really easy for me i don't have a
boss who's going to fire me for
something that i've said you know
um so yeah you could you could accuse me
of
of that and you would be right to to do
so but i just don't think i just
look i've got a teacher friend who's
going through this right now he's on
probation at this new school right so
he's got a year's probation
and um a year's probation so sorry
that's a teaching term which
basically you're you're being watched
for the first year of your employment to
make sure you don't put your foot wrong
basically
yeah and um it's not a bad term it's not
like the term it's not like
criminal it's not it's not what you're
thinking um
but he's not if he so he's being told
you know you're gonna have to talk about
white privilege teaching kids about
white privilege
all of this sort of um uh robin d'angelo
style stuff you know he's even been told
to read
white fragility by robert johnson stuff
like this so if you
if in his position he's he raises an
objection he's convinced that he won't
have his contract renewed that might be
true
but here's the alternative maybe most
people are secretly thinking the way
that he is thinking
and maybe if he were to say something
other people might say something
and then maybe you get this kind of
tipping point where everyone just says
yeah actually the emperor does have no
clothes on
so and it does take that even in the
most horrendous of circumstances
and i've used this analogy before but i
think it's it's exactly right
if you take what happened in salem
massachusetts with the witch trials
now there was a point where anyone who
cast any kind of skepticism on the
girl's testimony
on abigail williams and all the others
all the girls who were saying they could
see spirits and devils and all the rest
of it
anyone who did cast aspersions on that
or just say this isn't real
the girls then turned their fingers on
them and accused them
and they got hanged you know and
ultimately what is it 19 18 19 people
were hanged
in in salem but there came a point where
too many people started saying no
this isn't real this is a myth and the
reason and they couldn't hang everyone
and the real the real turning point was
when i think the governor's wife was
accused by the girls and at that point
of course
people felt a bit more empowered so
maybe it will be
when this stuff starts affecting the
people on their own
side you know or something like that i
mean already you're getting this kind of
this kind of uh change and i'm getting
more messages than ever
from people within either the comedy
community or the arts saying
oh this is going a bit far you know i've
always been on board with this wokester
but it's going a bit far now
i'm a bit nervous about it now and i
think
you will get a salem tipping point where
everyone just
says and it does have to start with a
few sacrificial lambs
unfortunately that you know it does
i don't think there was a little glint
in his eye as he said that but
uh you you talk about the the governor's
wife andrew one of the interesting
things for me that's happened i think a
lot of the people
who uh you know boris johnson said lent
him their vote and i include myself in
there i used to be a lib dem voter
voted label the previous election yeah
for the first time ever in my life i
voted for the
tories and that was mainly because i
thought uh well i thought even though i
voted remain i thought brexit had to be
had to be done because you're a democrat
right right yeah
uh unusual given my bag but nonetheless
but i thought brexit needed to be done
so democracy was important i thought
that
corbin was useless obviously and the
third thing i thought was
look boris johnson has hinted that on
this cultural stuff you know he's gonna
be you know he's not i don't think he
was gonna be some anti-woke
warlord but i didn't but i didn't think
he'd be particularly work and my sense
is both
to use your metaphor the government and
the government governor's wife
are actually sort of work
or or on on that on the path to that
yeah although
you know you get these sort of moments
don't you like with liz trusses speaking
yeah
the other day or or kenny badernock also
but i feel like that
every now and again they come out and
sort of throw a stake to
to the dogs but the rest of the time it
it's it's a it's a mega diet
yeah it is and i remember during the
height of the the black lives matter
stuff and i was and and all the critical
race theory stuff
i spoke to someone within uh you know
within the government
who said the trouble is no no one can
say anything you know because it would
it would have to be a person of color
for a start
to say anything and and and and and so
few people understand what's going on
and everyone's very nervous about it
understandably eventually beca i mean
kenny baden
did stand up and say and actually all
she did was reiterate the point that
that um
that you have to be impartial when it
comes to teaching
politics in schools but of course
because they hadn't associated critical
race theory but it is such an
essentially political
uh discipline so um so that you know
that shouldn't be a controversial thing
but you're right like
yeah i mean i think a lot of people did
lend their vote to uh johnson for the
same reason
i think brexit was the big thing though
but i think those other concerns were
were there as well that that maybe that
the tories would stand up
well if anyone was going to stand up
against this this ideology surely it
would be the tories but of course
it's so pervasive now its tentacles have
reached out so far
uh that it's it's it's in the tory party
as as well
so you know which means that we don't
really have
an option i mean can we really rely on
the occasional victory
can we really rely on the occasional
speech by liz trust or someone like that
is that sufficient
if the cabinet itself is is is is too
cowardly
to stand up to this stuff i mean i don't
know
but andrew going back uh to the crucible
which is
a brilliant play for you for those who
haven't read it um
at the end of the play because i used to
teach it john proctor says
you must leave me my name it's the only
thing that i have it's my name
but isn't that what people are worried
about when they're confronting this
stuff is that they will have their name
and their reputation slur they will be
tarnished as a racist a bigot whatever
else
and you know we joke about it but those
labels really hurt
and they're very very very destructive i
love that you've brought in a literary
illusion it's really raised the tone
it's so high brown now no you're right
john proctor says leave me my name
like he doesn't in a sense being
executed is is one thing but
reputation yeah i mean it it's more it's
more damaging than people understand
i think um i think it's different for us
because we're just so used to being
called these things
you know i think you just get used to
being called a nazi or whatever um
and and you just you just learn to
ignore it but um
because it well firstly it's probably
not true it's also weird because it's
the exact
opposite of my belief system it couldn't
be it couldn't be further removed
from what i believe so so in that sense
it's not worth getting upset about you
know
um but i understand you know if if
if you're being accused of these things
it's it's it's hurtful
um this is why ultimately i think the
brexit vote went the way it did i think
it tipped over the edge
because we had months and months of the
media saying that if you voted leave
that means you're a racist and of course
because the vast majority of people who
voted levar
aren't racist they resent the accusation
and therefore it's almost a kind of well
i'm gonna i'm gonna do what i
what i want then you know it's a it's a
it's a kind of [ __ ] you
um which i get i get that because nobody
responds well when they're being
insulted and this is ultimately why the
tactics of council culture won't
just just don't work all they do is
intimidate and and
put people in in a state of fear but
everyone can see
that it completely lacks basic human
empathy and compassion
and most people are just decent people
who who react against that kind of
inhumanity so
you know it's in that sense there's
something to be very optimistic about
and that i
i don't think those tactics uh will work
and you're right
you're right to mention the crucible and
that speech at the end
and and that does explain why people are
nervous about it rightly so because you
won't get a job
if you're called racist on social media
uh you won't get a job you know because
because most employers now just google
you don't they
yeah and they have a look at you at
what's been said about you and they're
not going to take the risk
that's all right we're hiring a
trigonometry no problem right
but that's but that's interesting isn't
it the fact that that tactic
can work undermines the purpose of the
tactic
it can only work because we live in a
society in which racism is not tolerated
that's the only reason it works
right whereas the people who use the
tactic of smearing people as racist they
do so because they believe our society
is built on that
it's actually it actually proves the
opposite the fact that everyone's so
terrified of being called a racist why
would we care
if racism was normalized and was
mainstream in our society why would you
care about being called racist wouldn't
affect your job prospects it'd be fine
the you know and this is this is the one
of the many
contradictions at the heart of cancer
culture andrew
it's interesting you've obviously talked
about brexit quite a bit and i brought
in
the lack of cultural activity from
from the tories you put those two things
together and it seems to me like we are
sort of preparing the ground for another
kind of potentially popular evolve
because if the democratic system isn't
representing
a significant uh viewpoint in the public
then what will eventually happen is
there will be some kind of uh uprising
against that not not a violent one or
anything like that
maybe a democratic one through some kind
of other party or whatever
do you think that the lack of
representation
uh of the cultural concerns that people
like us i think
uh voice and represent will eventually
lead to
a political movement and and that will
be the only way that any of this happens
i hope so yeah i mean i'm all for that i
think as many new
political parties as as possible as many
voices in in parliament
uh pushing back against this stuff it's
not even about winning the general
election it's about making those voices
heard
and not just having an opposition that
just echoes what the well the current
government says
uh when it comes to these particular
issues obviously they have they have
many points of disagreement but when it
comes to this stuff they're all in
lockstep
um and i think that that will be the
case i don't have any uh illusions that
we can
transcend the two-party system but i
think electoral reform would help if we
can somehow
get proportional representation and
maybe if we could get um
other smaller parties rising up i think
the sdp is basically right on everything
and i think it would be great and i
would have voted for them if there was a
candidate standing in my constituency
but there wasn't
uh so i spoiled my ballot but i think if
we could get someone like that
uh into parliament then then uh then
yeah you would get
uh sensible adult discussion restored i
think so
um i don't know about a revolt i think
if any revolt has to come it has to come
through the ballot box
you know if you want to live in a
civilized democracy that's what's that's
what's got to happen
agreed you know so hopefully yeah i
think that'd be great i mean
i'm not getting into politics god god
forbid you know i would never
uh consider that you should do it why
don't you start a trigonometry party you
know i think it would be the
trigonometry party
why not oh
my i think we get enough haters to see
you in parliament
i'd love to see you in parliament yeah
right the thing is right yeah
yeah you know you could do that what
about them [ __ ] pedos yeah i think it
happened like glenda jackson
became a very successful politician you
know you can be uh you can do this you
can you can follow her route
what do you think about that go on go on
francesca
one of you has got to step up because
i'm not going to do it you know
i think i think being a politician is
terrible because firstly everyone
obviously
uh that well particularly if you've been
a comedian because you know
anyone who's a politician the media are
going to dig into everything you've ever
said and as comedians
we've said a lot of offensive stuff
inadvertently actually because i'm not
particularly offensive comedian
but you could take some lines from my
stand up and and certainly paint a grim
picture
um as you could with any stand-up uh so
but also i think it's just towing the
party line i couldn't bear it i really
feel for those politicians whenever
they're on question time or something
and they can't answer a question
because they know that their their
honest answer would would go against the
party whip and and so therefore that you
see them squirming and i think it's
really
it's an unpleasant thing to watch and i
wouldn't want to participate
unless you just go full trump and double
down on everything and just be
completely unapologetic
yeah gain a massive fan base i'm all for
this i want as i said earlier i want
politicians just to say what they think
because at the moment all we're ever
doing is trying to fathom what they're
secretly thinking and trying to
trying to work out that's impossible for
one thing you can't actually do it
and it's just a waste of everyone's time
so if if everyone just said what they
honestly thought
then we could we'd know who we were
voting for and we could we could elect
the people that represent our values and
that
it would be i know this this sounds like
a really shocking system right
it's so basic it's so crazy
do you think everybody should be a
little bit more like andrew adonis
more like andrew adonis do you not
follow him on twitter mate
he is the best account he's way better
than titania i'm sorry to say this but
look you know i love you i think you're
a great writer but
andrew adonis is a much much higher
quality of troll
on the internet i know but look people
like that andrew adonis and
um pre-invader gopal at cambridge and
david lammy and
all the professional trolls on twitter
right but they know what they're doing
and when you talk to them
you know i i was recently trolled by
this academic i can't remember which
university he was at
and it was like it was like some
trucking a teenager
had got drunk and raided his parents
vodka cabinet and was
like it was just incredibly aggressive
and and
rude and weird and not listening and all
the rest of it and then i heard him on
radio 4 talking to melvin bragg and he
was really polite and
seemed quite nice and i bet the same is
true of like
of lamy and gopal and and and yes adonis
who you've met
i'm sure these are really nice people
and i bet i could sit down with any of
them have a sensible conversation
but as soon as i left they'd be on
twitter saying oh that scum nazi doyle
it's you know that's and that's a
weirdness there's a weirdness about it
there's a kind of performativity about
it
i have no doubt that sometimes adonis
sen puts a tweet out there and thinks i
don't really
i don't think that do i i'm just gonna
i'm just i mean
after the brexit deal he went on twitter
and said i think the best policy for the
united kingdom is to rejoin the european
union immediately
you cannot you cannot get better than
that we've got right we've got to give
him the benefit of the doubt and assume
he's lying
right because because otherwise he's
just being stupid and i don't think he
is stupid so
i think he's not he's a lovely man
as i said he interviewed him as i said
we both voted romaine
he was fun but as i said there's a level
of deludedness about that that i can't
believe that he actually is that deluded
but most people are just nice aren't
they most people are just nice when you
when you when you meet them and talk to
them
um i bet even the most vicious trolling
you get
if you spoke to them they'd be they'd be
just really nice and probably a bit
embarrassed
um by what by what they said and i'm
sure the same goes for these these kinds
of
these kinds of people um uh but yeah i
mean
yeah i think with adonis i could
literally cut and paste some of his
tweets
and put them out as titania i've done
that a few times
from prominent uh sort of celebrity
activists
you know and uh it's it's always quite
fun to do because i'm continually told
that the stuff that she says is like a
straw man and these people don't exist
but this is why in the when i wrote the
first book it's interspersed on every
page
with quotations from real life activists
which are exactly the same as what
tatani is saying
you know i'm trying to make the point
that it is it is the same it is the same
thing
and and actually the accusation of straw
manning is completely demonstrably
false um uh you know i could put out
some of adonis's tweets or lammy's
tweets and you would say i've made that
no one would actually say that
well yeah it's actually a member of the
house of lords he's who said that you
know
but do you not find it a little bit
depressing but using david lammy as an
example so
lammy round about 2011 you would say
that he'd be very much a blue labor
acolyte those were the policies that he
espoused the policies that he
supported and all the rest of it and
we've slowly seen him drift towards that
extreme we've seen people
who are center right drift towards the
other extreme do you think as a society
we're simply not going to get more and
more polarized
maybe i mean i i hope i hope not i i
think
i think again people went a bit mad you
know i i i've
come to i mean i'm really torn on this
because i've essential optimism about
humanity and the goodness of human
beings
but i also can see so much evidence from
the past four years of the propensity
for
hysteria and there's no other word to
describe it the stuff about brexit you
know we we
our democracy is sustained on the losers
consent as you know
and the utter hysteria of going out in
droves painting your face in the eu flag
and
screaming gammon at everyone and calling
everyone a fascist
about membership of an international
trading block that you didn't care about
before 2016.
you didn't pay it a second thought you
cannot be this passionate about
something
unless what it is is a kind of religious
devotion that that's the only
explanation for this i mean sure there
have been some people who have always
been passionate about the eu but you
could fill them in like one church hall
or something
there's not many uh in fact most of the
people who were talking about the eu
most of the discourse about the eu
from the past 30 years in advance of the
referendum was in fact people who wanted
to leave you know had the like the
referendum party back in the 1980s and
then of course
ukip and all the rest of it and nigel
farage so it wasn't
people who were celebrating the eu and
talking about how wonderful it was they
didn't care about it
they just didn't care and i don't
believe you can go from complete
apathy to uh extreme
zealous passion where you hate anyone
who disagrees with you on that i don't
think that can happen
if it's been thought through from a
position of rationality that has to be
a kind of hysterical earth phenomenon
that's what that is
um and and you know i think when when
you see people tweeting the way you've
described they are succumbing to a
hysteria
when david lammy talks about how the erg
are worse than nazis or whatever it was
he said
i'm paraphrasing there that's someone
succumbing to hysteria
that's not someone who's thinking
rationally and because i have a belief
in him as he's an obviously intelligent
man so i believe that in about five
years time he'll be able to look back on
that
and say yeah he'll be able to put his
hands up and say that was stupid wasn't
it he will
because we all have the capacity to say
stupid things in the heat at the moment
particularly when emotion is heightened
who hasn't i have
you have everyone who hasn't done that
and i think most of us
have the humility to be able to say yes
that was a mistake
and i and i do believe that will be the
case i believe in about 10 years time
all of the people who had the f what is
it fbp
uh hashtag the real angry
uh you know the bullies online they're
really vicious ones you know
i think they'll look back and say i
cannot believe i behaved so
disgracefully i can't believe
i smeared all these people as nazis i
can't believe i i lost my senses and i
do believe that will happen
particularly once we're out the eu
because i mean it's not something that
anyone would rejoin
sensibly i mean this was one of the
strongest arguments i thought during the
brexit debate
if if we weren't in the eu and the
debate was about should we join
that would have been a very difficult
argument to win you know not least
because the the eu has such a terrible
track record of economic growth but
but quite aside from that it's it's it's
it's borderline racist policies when it
comes to
immigration and things like that would
have put a lot of people off
it's complete bureaucracy uh it's
complete democratic unaccountability all
of this stuff
you know if you just said we're going to
subscribe to this thing that's going to
make anywhere between 30 and 60
of our laws and regulations but we will
have no means to vote these people
out the left would never have gotten
bored with that
certainly not and and you would never
been to be able to persuade the
population to get on board it just
wouldn't have happened
so i think ultimately you know look at
someone like ac grayling
who is a tremendously talented writer i
mean he's a philosopher obviously but
if you've ever read any of his books he
is calm he is measured he is collected
he's forensic
in some of his analysis um and yet
his behavior on twitter is like a child
when it comes to brexit it's like it's
it's like a child who doesn't
who hasn't even thought this through can
only think in terms of
of of of good versus evil who could only
think in these
these black and white it's it's it's
almost sad
to see someone of such stature degrade
himself to this degree
and i just wonder again i hope there is
the possibility of redemption i hope
in it you know i i mean i look at some
of those tweets i'd be so ashamed
to have written those tweets he can't
see it at the moment but you may believe
andrew this is where even though i'm
very optimistic and i was hoping we
would have a more light-hearted
conversation but it is what it is
because that's how we feel
my concern is that with the existence of
social media now
in the past if you'd made mistakes those
mistakes
could only be used against you for so
long before they were sort of
purged from the public record you know
if you made some innocuous
or maybe inappropriate but it's not
particularly major
comments 10 years ago you know people
moved on it wasn't really
there easily accessible it was hard to
find it might have been covered in a
newspaper article or whatever but it
wasn't really
a thing nowadays all your history is
there forever
and i think that also one of the things
that does is it actually makes it quite
a lot a lot more difficult to go
you know what actually i don't like the
person i used to be
and i and to me you know i've always
thought about it if i
don't like the person i was 10 years ago
i've always seen that as a sign of
progress
i've always thought well of course i
think i was an idiot at 18
right because i'm now bigger better
stronger more intelligent
more emotionally intelligent whatever
i'm not sure
young people or frankly anyone at this
point has that luxury anymore because
if you start to move away from your
previous position
someone is instantly going to pop up and
go well this is what you said
you know yeah and the example you gave
of the the
15 year old who put that video out yeah
that example that it's going to be held
on to yeah that's true and
but but i think the the re the reason to
be cheerful with this
is that everyone knows this to be the
case right everyone i mean i i remember
seeing a play at the end of a fridge by
a friend of mine
and she writes for the guard you know
she's a very very um pro social justice
writer a very good writer
and um the play was about how anyone's
life can be ruined
if you have complete access to
everything they've ever texted or
tweeted or
or written in an email there is no one
who who would not fall foul of that
because anything can be selected
uh can be taken selectively against you
um
and used against you and also people
change like you say and and
and people make mistakes more
importantly and no one is morally pure
or morally uh infallible and so the
expectation that people should be is
is is actually unworkable and i think
because everyone knows that
even the woke they know that because
because so many of them
get eaten by their own um everyone's
just living in this
continual state of fear and that's not
something that anyone wants it's not
desirable for anyone
so i think um yeah i
that's something i really wish we could
change i wish we could change this idea
that just because you said something 10
years ago
it still counts against you you know uh
and that's not to say you don't take
responsibility for the things you've
said
but you should be allowed to change your
mind you should be allowed to grow as a
person and move on as a person i mean
this is
these are basic principles of humanity
more than anything else um
and i hope we can do something about
that as of next year this is why i think
we need to be better as well i think i
think people on all sides of this debate
should not be dragging up things that
our opponents have said many years ago i
think it happens on both sides
and i uh and and of course the
temptations there because you want to
point out hypocrisy
of someone i mean i saw this happen uh
the other week where
i won't mention the name but it's a very
very famous uh left-wing journalist
um who who loves to engage in council
culture and call people out well someone
called up
something that he'd written while at
university
uh and put on on on the internet and it
did paint him in a very bad light but i
thought
you know if we start doing that then we
lose all moral high ground everyone's
just got to stop
stop doing that that doesn't mean not
holding people to account it doesn't
mean challenging people when they say
things
but it does mean uh just not dragging
through people's past and expecting
everyone to be morally pure because that
just gets us nowhere once if you destroy
someone with facts and logic
like me is that what you that's what you
guys do isn't it
that's how you label your videos isn't
it destroying libtards with facts
no we've never we've never ever
i know i was i was mischaracterizing you
you are
you you're smearing us with your
right-wing opinions andre
i know i love that though because that's
i get this all the time i'm called an
edge lord and
oh so i love this though because
whenever someone does this to me online
and they say oh
you your whole career is is bitching
about snowflakes and libtards and i just
say
can you find me one example of when i've
ever said either of those things just
one
because if it's my whole career if it's
my whole shtick this should be a really
easy task for you
and the fact that i can't find anything
because i've never done it i love it
like
the the the claims of i had one the
other day some academic oh no writer i
think he's a journalist saying that
i've i'm bit i'm whinging again because
i wrote an article about
my experiences when i came out as
titania amongst the comedy community
and he was saying look at him again
whinging about how he's got no voice and
how he's being censored all the time and
being cancelled and he can't say what he
thinks
but here he is being paid to write an
article i'm like i've never made the
claim
i've never made the claim and if you
think that's all i ever do
you should easily be able to find an
example shouldn't you and if you can't
maybe you might want to reflect on the
validity of your criticism but of course
that would take a degree of
introspection that a lot of these people
do not possess
well i never i never i would never use
the word libtard mainly because i'm
liberal myself right so right i know and
i just also don't find that sort of
language unhelpful andrew so let's
let's look at some of the what has been
amusing you the most this year what have
you found really funny
there have been loads there've been
loads of things so i actually made a a
little list
oh did you uh of of the various things
that have been happened this year and
some of the some of the amazing ones
i mean there's so many like so i was
just going through the year and i was
thinking what happened
when and there's just been some some
astonishing things happening so like in
january for instance
when the the pink news started praising
pakistan because they said they were
going to subsidize trans surgery
and of course the reason the government
was doing that is because if you're gay
you're in a lot of trouble so they they
incur it was actually a homophobic
thing and then the pink news which is
meant to be a gay publication were
praising this homophobic policy
i thought that was hilarious a bit scary
but but
but but but quite funny oh the one i
loved in january was the um
sheffield university paying its students
nine pound 34 an hour
to spy on fellow students in case they
said any racial microaggressions
that was amazing and that because that
was i mean you talk about comparing with
the soviet union that
that was pure that's that's that's pure
soviet style isn't it no
it's not pure so let's let's not get our
wires twisted here it's much better than
the soviets
in the soviet union those jobs were
unpaid that's true yeah so at least
you're
making a buck out of it exactly exactly
so capitalism at work this is brilliant
i mean yeah so that was incredible um
the
uh the the constant cancellations
throughout the year
and yet people talk about how cancer
culture is a myth that's really funny to
me
that's really funny to me there's a
there's a thread online i should send
you the link
uh which records every instance of
cancellation it's thousands long
and it's just con it's just it's just
non-stop and the very people
who perpetuate it say yeah it's just a
it's just a right-wing myth no one's
no one's being no one's lost their job
because of something they've said
no that's never happened it's like that
that to me
is just hilarious that's really great um
i quite enjoyed the oscars i quite
enjoyed the um
jane fonda having ethically sourced
diamonds
i love the hypocrisy of that i love
natalie portman with her dior cape
embroidered with the female directors
who should have got the nomination that
was quite funny
um just the incredible lack of
self-awareness when the most privileged
people in the world
are hectoring everyone else uh of course
we've had that with megan and
megan and harry as well i mean they're
particularly funny because they'll
they'll they'll hector everyone about
their carbon footprint then fly off to
out in john's house for a private party
and their private jet so that's
that's inherently funny um you know it's
just funny when someone's telling you
about privilege you know he did a big
thing about white privilege it's like
you're a prince
you're an actual prince you're not in a
position to
to lecture us about privilege you're
just not um
so there's all of that um there's what
else has been
been quite good oh yeah all the
revisionist stuff has been quite
interesting
like i think the removal of the native
american indian from the land of lakes
butter pack
uncle ben's rice that's been dixed um
all of that kind of stuff as though this
will do anything at all i mean in the
case of the land of lakes thing that was
designed by a
native american artist if anything this
is a
this is attacking that person's cultural
heritage but in the name of
progress so all of that's been quite
interesting and of course all the uh
the the the the see there's there's been
something disturbing about the mobs
tearing down statues and i don't want to
undermine how
how anti-democratic and problematic that
is right to use one of their phrases
but by the same token the overreach of
some of it has been
has been funny when they start targeting
mahatma gandhi because he didn't what
did he ever do
um or or or or you know winston
churchill
you know the man who defeated fascism or
abraham lincoln
i mean wanting to tear down statues of
abraham lincoln you think he'd get a
free pass
for the whole abolition of slavery thing
you would think but it's not there
but my favorite was the british library
you know they have this decolonizing
working group at the british library
who decided that they need to revisit
all of their western manuscripts
why it's a library it's a repository of
historical artifacts
you know so you don't need to go through
it and flag up where things are
problematic they even made the mistake
of saying that
ted hughes was now a problem because of
some tenuous relationship to an ancestor
from the 16th century who he wasn't even
related to
you know and the best thing about the
decolonizing working group at the
british library is that they claimed
that the architecture of the building
itself was colonial because it looks a
bit like a battleship
so that stuff is funny to me so all of
this stuff
these things are they're great they're
ripe for comedy
if they weren't quite so sinister i
really like this so andrew because if
you think about it like the historical
aspect of your your uh descendants being
punished for things you say like
there is a guy who descended from me
four centuries down the line he was
absolutely [ __ ] doesn't he yeah oh
yeah you're you i mean you are you are
ruining
your i mean you don't have children
right
no no yeah so right well maybe you
shouldn't
because you're basically condemning them
you know exactly i'm not a breeder so i
don't have to worry about that but you
know
i i love that sort of sins of the father
business i mean you can't even pin that
on me because all of my ancestors were
you know i irish in the bogs you know
being sort of
colonized themselves so i mean you know
i i don't get to inherit
uh that guilt um or maybe did they have
their pronouns in their bio
they probably did they were good people
and like
you and yours good moral people yeah
andrew listen it's been great having you
back man
uh we wish you all the best uh give our
viewers some thoughts about
what you see happening in 2021 what are
you excited about for next year
uh i've written a book on free speech
which i'm very excited about i wrote it
in lockdown so you know
silver linings you know i was it forced
a kind of
disciplined work ethic on me you know it
was meant that i had nowhere to go so i
was writing which was good
um and that is called free speech and
why it matters
and that is going to be published uh in
february
so it's all very quick and very excited
about that and um and the idea of that
is i wanted it to be like
it's not a long book it's a short punchy
uh sort of covering or what i
what i perceive to be the most important
arguments in relation to this
the free speech battle and i do perceive
it as a battle in so far as
i i like i said i don't think we're
there yet we're not facing but we we are
definitely experiencing the early signs
of some very just a very disturbing road
that we're going down
and i think we need to be well equipped
to deal with that to
to have the arguments in place you know
so really what the book is doing is
going through systematically all the
various
reservations that people understandably
have you know because everyone hates it
when you hear some idiot
stand up and say the most horrible thing
and your instinct is to shut them up
your ins it makes sense that people want
to phone the police and all the rest of
it you know and so i i'm trying to
approach that from a
sympathetic perspective i'm not just
saying oh everyone's got to man up and
stop being snowflakes which is what
people will
doubtlessly say that i'm saying because
they won't read the thing
but i think we need to understand why
people have reservations about free
speech
understand why they want limitations on
it and then
talk about the dangers of that and
explain to people why
however well-intentioned that might be
uh that is a
is a perilous uh road to go down so
that's that's what
so that's why i'm quite excited about
that because i think it's um
it's nice to have a book out that isn't
written as a 24 year old woman
you know because you know the last two
books i've done have been to tarnier
books and
so a book in my own name would be would
be rather nice um
and uh yeah and then i'm i'm also
working on another book
which should be ready by the end of next
year about the culture war so
those two things are happening uh i'm
hoping
that i can tour with titania later in
the year because that tour has been
postponed
you know the live to tiny show which was
meant to be last march and then it was
this march and
so hopefully that'll be in november um
hopefully the show with douglas murray
will be going ahead the
show at the hammersmith apollo which is
scheduled at the moment for
late june so who knows maybe have to
wait and see what happens with the um
with the vaccine and the regulations in
the lockdown and all the rest of it but
hopefully hopefully
that's what i'm looking forward i'm
really looking forward to everything
getting back to normal
right now i'm stupidly optimistic though
he is a comedian
yeah that's what i want that's what you
want well thank you
so much for coming on the show andrew uh
your books will be released
uh in february and later on um the one
question that we always finish with
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
and i knew you were going to ask that
because you asked it every time and yet
i still don't have an
answer isn't that interesting why
couldn't i have simply prepared
something
why can't i have done something i could
have then i could have finished on a
flourish
and as it is it's a damp squib it is uh
but at least you told us
and all our viewers about the books
you're now using to cash in on your
right-wing bigotry
so there we are exactly so you know the
threats to free speech are great for my
bank balance apparently i'm just getting
in there early because that's what
people are going to say
rather than my career depends on these
two books about
how you've been censored uh as as the
guardian review will no doubt say andrew
it's been great having you back
and thank you all for watching this has
been our final
interview of the year we wish you all
the best we'll see you in 2021
when hopefully all of us will be
cancelled and then it's not going to
matter if you've been cancelled
absolutely if you don't get canceled the
virus will get you see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
triggerpod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word